thank you so much to uh lab roots for
inviting me to give a keynote
presentation today and uh for
to marilyn roose for thinking of me and
suggesting me to lab roots
today i'd like to talk about the work of
my laboratory
and many other laboratories uh
investigating the role of
viruses in natural ecosystems
so uh billions of times a day
uh this process of a virus
finding its microbial cell in this case
we have a
zoomed in view of t4
finding its specific receptors on the
surface
of e coli and then this fantastic
molecular machine
delivers its genome into
e coli piercing through the bacterial
cell wall which is
a non-trivial uh task as any of us who
work on bacteria know
and the the the dna
of t4 quickly replicates
and within 20 minutes
200 viral particles are produced and so
this very process is happening
throughout eco
natural ecosystems everywhere
and our questions are how is that
impacting
ecosystems
and uh one of the things that really
started uh
the field was discovery that viruses are
extraordinarily abundant
in natural ecosystems a typical seawater
sample which is shown in the
upper left-hand corner of the slide this
is a transmission electron micrograph
shows all these virus particles as well
as a bunch of bacterial cells
typically viruses outnumber cells by a
factor of 10.
the image at the lower left produced by
a colleague jed furman
at the university of southern california
shows an epi fluorescence microscope
microscope image you can see in the
middle middle
a penny diatom um some bacteria but that
cloud of small
particles in the in the white circle are
virus particles
um a a really fun website called what if
uh took all the viruses out of the ocean
would form a pile
of viruses that would dwarf new york
city
um we've there's been estimates that is
number 10 to the 31
on planet earth uh which is
far more than the age of the universe or
even the number of observable stars in
the universe
and you know interestingly enough our
own genome is uh
is is eight percent uh viral
another interesting thing is that
viruses are really
unknown their genetic composition is
extraordinarily unknown we have a
a bioinformatics pipeline known as virom
and
in virum we have attempted to take
all of these predicted open reading
frames predicted genes
and classify them according to whether
they have a known function or an unknown
function
and um what you can see is that
uh in the vast majority of the sequences
that we see
in viral meta genomes have homology to
only other unknown sequences in the
environment
this is extraordinarily high for soils
90 of of open reading frames are only
seen in the environment never been seen
in a known
organism so we have a lot of unknown we
have a lot of viruses
um but surely among the top
100 most abundant genes we must know
something right
and so this uh diagram shows a
clustering
of uh of predicted uh
peptides from viral metagenomes
and uh in its rank order these are the
top 100 most abundant clusters from a
number of different bureaus
and we thought well surely we know most
of these right well
not really so it turns out that
that proportion that high proportion of
over 60
of the genes being unknown is true for
um for even the top 100 most abundant
peptides predicted genes within viral
metagenomes
and this problem is pretty astounding
when you think
about the amount of sequence data we
have now available
through largely through metagenomics
from viruses so this
plot shows the extraordinary growth in
the number of
uncultivated viral genomes uh as of 2018
it was around uh 700 000 i think it's
probably
well into the millions now uh given the
amount of sequencing that we've done so
really
um we as with a lot of modern biology
getting genome data
is uh is easy now uh the problem is
getting understanding from all of this
sequence data
um so to start off i'd like to just give
three sort of examples um some vignettes
about
you know what these unknown and
extraordinarily abundant
viruses are doing to ecosystems and so
you know three
three ways in which marine viruses
affect you
um uh fishing rain and
oxygen so what are you talking about so
first of all
um virus isn't good fishing so um
the western uh edges of continents
tend to have great fishing and it's
largely because of physical oceanography
we get these are upwelling zones and so
here you can see the uh in on the
left-hand panel
um the upwelling zone off the eastern
united states
and uh and the upwelling zone off the
eastern
or sorry western coast of south america
these upwelling zones are
extraordinarily productive supporting
very large fisheries
and also these upwelling zones have
outsized impacts on the global carbon
cycle
so it turns out that the most limiting
nutrient
for phytoplankton in the ocean is iron
uh the difference between
the concentration of iron inside a
phytoplankton cell and outside of
phytoplankton cell
is about 19 0001 in the ocean
and so um a colleague of mine at the
university of tennessee steve wilhelm
asked the question well what if that
source of iron matters
and so what this plot shows is uh
the best source of iron meaning the the
most bioavailable source of iron
is from a viral lysate uh and not
uh some of the other forms of iron that
we use in
growing uh phytoplankton um in
in culture like chelated iron with edta
and so that was a very interesting
observation
and so steve's lab went and did uh some
calculation
of the mass balance of iron necessary to
support the productivity
of the peruvian upwelling zone and they
concluded
that up to 80 percent of the
demand for iron for phytoplankton growth
in the peruvian upwelling zone
was actually supplied through viral
lysis
so this idea that viruses make available
trace nutrients for
more growth is an important ecosystem
consequence of viral lysis
so viruses make rain this sounds a
little extraordinary
um but uh in high latitudes or
high latitudes around uh in the northern
hemisphere around the
the united kingdom uh and and a belt
going across
you know i guess about uh sort of 50 to
60 degrees north
maybe as deep as 40 degrees north and
there's another band
around the southern hemisphere this
organism or these or this group of
organisms called
coccolithophores uh can bloom in
tremendous numbers and so what you're
seeing
in this image is the southern coast of
england
and this milky seas phenomena where
these cockalithophores which have
these calcium carbonate shells on the
outside of the cell which you can see
in the upper left-hand part of the
figure
form and so when these organisms bloom
you literally get an enormous amount of
calcium carbonate and this carbonate
actually sinks out
and has contributed to massive
geological objects like the white cliffs
of dover
well it turns out that this
coccolithophore has a virus
has it actually a giant virus and
a colleague of mine willie wilson uh
in the uk asked a question of
you know when the viruses lyse the cells
what happens and so one of the things
is coccolithophores and many
phytoplankton
have to have osmo protectants and one of
these osmo protectants is dimethyl
sulfoxide propionate
well when the viruses lyse the cells
that osmoprotectin is released it's
processed by bacteria into a volatile
sulfur compound known as dimethyl
sulfide
dimethyl sulfide is what really gives
the sea that
sulfury kind of smell and the sulfate
aerosols
are very important in forming cloud
condensation nuclei which is actually a
negative
feedback on the growth of more
phytoplankton because it forms more
clouds
and um uh willie actually
um established this what this plot shows
is a the growth of an e huxley eye
culture
which is the purple or sorry the pink
um uh uh line
and then added viruses uh which is the
blue line
and then the red line is a pulse of
dimethyl sulfoxide that comes
out of uh the culture
once viruses peak and that's when you're
getting peak levels
of lysis of those cells and this
how you know so how important is this
process well it's
second to the most important process
which is actually grazing
of the coccolithophores by things like
copepods
and it's actually even more important
than just the lysis of
autolysis of the cells themselves
the last little vignette here is if
you're breathing
thank a cyanophage and we're all
breathing so um
cyanophages are phages that infect
cyanobacteria and
what you see here on the left is
a dividing prochlorococcus cell
and these uh um cyanobacteria are
abundant in regions of the ocean
uh where really nothing there's not a
whole lot going on
and so what i have circled are the
oceanic
gyres in the image on the right
and that's the domain of prochlorococcus
and prochlorococcus like many
microorganisms have
viruses that infect it and it was
discovered
by nick mann and uh also debbie lindell
that actually curiously enough these
cyanophages infecting uh prochlorococcus
carry photosynthetic genes and the
reason they do this we believe
is that the photosystem turns over very
rapidly
in the cyanobacterial cell and anything
that interrupts protein synthesis
like growing a new virus will interrupt
the production of these rapidly uh
turning over
photosynthetic proteins and so literally
the virus
is the idea is that the virus is
sustaining the photosystem
during infection so that it can make
more cyanophages
um and uh and given the
levels of infection
uh occurring uh and and the fact that
these cyanobacteria provide about 50
percent
of the oxygen in the atmosphere
if we rough numbers say that about 10
of these cells are likely infected by a
cyanophage containing
photosynthetic genes uh then it's
possible that as much as five percent of
global oxygen production
actually comes from cyanophages and is
sustained by cyanophages so that's one
out of every 20 breaths
so um hopefully i've convinced you that
these viruses of microbes have pretty
substantial ecosystem
impacts we've been reminded through the
covet pandemic
that viruses change host behavior which
indeed changes ecosystems and in in this
case it's
humanity and so the lockdowns that
occurred in
uh china and india are currently
occurring just about everywhere
have had a tremendous impact on air
quality
these graphics show on the left the
level
of nitrogen dioxide a potent
air pollutant in china before and after
the lockdown
and then just the pictures in
new delhi of the air quality one year
later
after the pandemic is pretty striking
so you know what what are viruses doing
why do they matter
and and and what's the big picture
questions that that my lab and
several others uh uh
pursue first of all we they move
nutrients around they influence
productivity uh and that
like for instance the fishing story
because they they're releasing
micronutrients but really
by how much is this process important we
know that in the peruvian upwelling it
is extremely important but
what about other ecosystems um
we also know i didn't talk about this a
lot but viruses move genes around
especially important for clonal
organisms
and so which genes are most moved around
and why
are those genes moved around through
horizontal gene transfer and
using viruses as a vector
they also you know virus host
interactions are very specific and so
how
would on a on a community basis that
specific process of viral infection
influence the composition of the host
community
and what are those specific effects we
also know that
by one a cell is infected its biology is
very different so what are those
specific effects on hosts
and how do all of these emerge to have
impact on ecosystems so these are really
the you know second third order
questions that are our drivers
the approach that we use um is
uh our metagenomics has become
extraordinarily important to
approaching these questions and
my uh dr the driving hypothesis of my
lab is that genome
to phenome connections will really drive
us towards answering these questions
um and when so what have gotten the
graphic here is that we specifically
isolate viral dna um
from ecosystems and then sequence that
in meta genomes
and the question i want to know is
or is to identify viral populations
within that community and then
understand something of their biology
understand something of their life
history as we say as ecologists
and those life history features are
really to do with the viral infection
process
and viral host interaction so what is
the burst size of the virus it's latent
period
what kind of life cycle does it have is
it lysogenic
is it lytic is it pseudo lysogenic is it
chronic
um what is the host range of the virus
how many different hosts could
different host populations could it
infect how fast is the virus lost from
the system this is a very important
consideration and
lastly how infectious is it and i think
as
as kovit has taught us these are big
questions for viruses
and the more we understand the more we
can model
any sort of epidemic
and really all of those summarized come
together to understand how viruses
changed host biology change host biology
and ecology
and this will help us to understand
those emergent impacts that i've talked
about
so an approach that we've taken is to
really focus
on the few genes that we can identify
that are abundant
uh and that we know something about and
so we focused on peptide and nuclei
nucleotide synthesis genes i'm only
going to talk about the nucleotide
synthesis genes today
but we did discover and this is the
graphic i showed earlier
that you know dna polymerase is a very
abundant
enzyme ribonucleotide reductase and
grow yes is uh is a chaperonin or it's
the small subunit of the chaperone and
we have actually found the large subunit
chaperonin i won't talk about that today
but all of these are found in viruses um
they're uh you know critical to phage
biology nucleotide
synthesis is at the core of what a virus
needs to do
and this is especially important for
lytic viruses because they need to
quickly infect and then produce and find
the next host
there's also intriguingly enough many of
these genes are obviously shared between
cellular life and viruses so
we can start to see those deep
phylogenetic connections and the
differences
in um selective pressures on these genes
in viruses versus cells
and really those phylogenetic analyses i
believe
are the foundation of the first step
towards greater biological understanding
and so we've looked at known phages
and uh asked well you know just how
abundant are these genes
because the thing about viruses is
they're polyphyletic in their origin so
there's no single marker that's going to
capture all of viral diversity
no single gene um but if we can find
some common genes
they may tell us something interesting
about evolution and biology
and so it turns out that uh family a uh
dna polymerases are
very common among unknown viruses 26
of known viruses have them
ribonucleotide reductase is also very
common
um it may actually be more uncommon in
the
unknown viruses in the environment than
actually in our cultivated
representatives
um so the first work i want to talk
about is our work with
dna polymerase a and these three
students
contributed an enormous amount of work
to this
um to this project our ongoing project
uh so paul a is um
it occurs in bacteria uh it is a in
bacteria it's a relatively low
processivity polymerase um it functions
in repair
it removes primers fills in okazaki
fragments it's not the
workhorse for cells however
in phages it is their primary replicates
and it has a very different character
very different biochemical
characteristics and phages
so for instance in phage t7 which is the
one we know the most about
has a very high catalytic efficiency um
intriguingly enough
we wouldn't have sequencing today
without pull a
because it was the basis of the first
sequencing enzyme
helen uh schmidt was a undergraduate in
my lab and
happened to be also a biochemistry major
which helped a lot with this
project and helen discovered
uh first of all looking through you know
our our vira our um
metagenome samples typically what the
graphic
at the top shows is that in viruses this
is a smaller enzyme
the five prime to three-pound exo is is
not present um that's the proof-reading
part
and uh the the known uh
known viruses tend to have smaller
versions of the gene
this is not unusual for um for viruses
they tend to
whatever gene they have they tend to
make it uh small and efficient
and helen noted that there was a motif
where
a particular uh this is a motif
intricate to the active action of the
polymerase
that a single mutation in motif b is
responsible for pretty dramatic changes
in the enzyme now this is known from in
vitro studies with the t7 dna polymerase
so if you the the wild type in bacteria
all bacteria
have uh the phenylalanine um 762
position
if that phenylalanine is um
is mutated to a tyrosine there's a
dramatic
increase in the catalytic efficiency and
this even is the
mutation that allows for the
incorporation of dideoxynucleotides for
sequencing
if you change that to a leucine the
efficiency goes
down but the fidelity goes up so this is
very very interesting
and helen had um
this is this slide shows a uh a
phylogram
of our viral polymerases as well as
uh bacterial polymerases and so the
bacterial polymerase is from a vast
diversity of
of bacteria scanning from seneca cockat
or from
from prochlorococcus all the way to
thermos aquaticus and e coli
fairly monophyletic but as we look at
the same enzyme and viruses we get this
explosion of diversity and i'm pointing
out three specific
subclades here um the the blue subclade
is our
t7 like clay this this it turns out all
the polymerases
in this clay contained the 762 mutation
um then the red one which is sort of
like
our our type strain there is uh
colophage t5
had the phenylalanine mutation we're
calling that neutral and then the purple
was comprised almost entirely of
environmental sequences
and that contained the 762 mutation
there was
a distant related phage of an alpha
proteobacteria that was actually a
pseudo-lysagenic
um uh phage and so
looking at this and i won't show this
data but helen went
and looked at all known phages and it
turns out
that known phages having this enzyme
it looks like these different
clades are actually linked with phage
life cycle
so the the upper two the blue
and the red appear to be only in lytic
phages whereas the purple one
appeared to be largely in lysogenic and
pseudo-lysogenic phages and so here we
may have
our hypothesis is that a single mutation
in pole a
may be linked with the life cycle of
unknown viruses
and what i'm talking about here um is
the
lytic or lysogenic life cycle so shown
on the left is the lysogenic or pseudo
lysogenic life cycle
where the phage actually enters this
this phase of being
carried by the host and may or may not
produce viruses eventually and then the
lytic where you get an infection
and then quick replication and lysis of
the cell
one thing that has been an extraordinary
help to us in all of this work
with um with uh with replication
proteins and with chaperonins is
has been long reads and so um
we have a a library that we a
viral metagenome library that we
sequenced using
pac bio and uh and as this slide should
this table shows what i want to point
out here
is that we get a far higher yield of
full-length polymerases from hybrid
assembly of pac bio reeds
as well as alumina reads and this is
very important because it is a very
large
uh protein upwards of 700 amino acids in
in size um and so um
as the more we can apply long read
technology to meta genomes the more we
can really
build these genome hypothesis genome to
phenomena hypotheses
later work done with one of these long
read libraries
um the the cirque library
found an extraordinary amount of pull a
diversity
within the chesapeake bay and so what
this slide shows this venn diagram
shows is the circ library which is in
blue
the blue circle over on the left and
the and um more traditionally illumina
or actually this was 454 sequenced
metagenome libraries viral metagenome
libraries
known as metagenomes online a database
we maintain
and as you can see the
two-thirds of known polar viral
diversity was actually found in one
chesapeake bay sample so i think if you
want to
get a deep sampling of viruses and on
earth
go to the chesapeake bay it is a highly
diverse microbial ecosystem
um and uh and as you can see
the the small balls within the venn
diagram are actually
clusters of pole a peptides
and um you notice that the colors are
pretty exclusive and so uh it turns out
that these uh these markers this single
a mutation actually links with large 75
percent
uh clusters we get very few mixed
clusters
and uh which indicates to me that this
this particular mutation is
extraordinarily important in driving the
evolution of the entire
molecule we've also gone out and looked
at
the gene neighbors of uh pole a
in hopes of gathering more information
about uh the replication module itself
and as we've loaded on more sequences
we've actually seen
some of the clades actually split the
phenylalanine group has split into two
the leucine group is split into two but
that tyrosine group
um and that's all in the tree shown on
the left
has maintained its uh it's clading
and it's sort of monophyletic nature
and so one of the interesting things
that we we started to look at well
what is around poland and could that
help us
understand its biochemistry and
its impact on the biology of virus a
little bit more and so when we look at
the tyrosine clay it was very
interesting
both the tyrosine and the phenylalanine
clade is that
they also contained uh ring-shaped
helicases
which are the helicase on lines of dna
and they were highly processive fast
helicases
that were associated with those
phenylalanine and tyrosine
pole a's which is what you would need
for a very
fast replicating polymerase another
thing that was interesting
is we also found ribonucleotide
reductase
associated with those same pole a's as
shown in
the the lower half of the diagram
and we almost never saw rnr
with the leucine pole a's so why is this
interesting well
it turns out that rnr is the only enzyme
that can actually
process ribonucleotides into
deoxyribonucleotides and of course
deoxyribonucleotides are the essential
substrate for pole a
so if a virus carries an rnr it's
actually controlling
the availability of the substrate for
dna synthesis which would be
again very important to a lytic virus
which needs to produce
lots of dna and do it very quickly in
contrast when we look at the top
of the leucine polars those are the ones
that are slower but
more have higher fidelity they don't
have
rnr and so it's possible that these are
lysogenic viruses that are it's much
more nuanced
they are actually controlling the host
utilizing
the host machinery for making uh
deoxyribonucleotides
they replicate slower but their fidelity
is better
and so there's these trade-offs that we
think we're seeing
so i'm going to transition here and talk
about uh rnr a little more in depth
um it is an ancient enzyme likely
responsible or at the
at the transition between rna world and
dna world
um it comes in a number of uh different
biochemical classes i'll talk about in a
minute
um it regulates the available pull of
ribonuc of deoxynucleotides for dna
synthesis
um it increases the rate of dna
synthesis tenfold
when it's present in a viral genome um
there's some thinking that it may be it
may have a role in
phosphorus recycling in nutrient limited
environments of course phosphorus is
very important in dna synthesis
or nucleotide synthesis period um
and we find that it is very common in
soil and environmental genome libraries
probably more common than even we see in
known
phages one of the interesting things
about robin nuclear type reductase of
course
anything having a dna genome needs this
enzyme
so that would include all cellular life
so all cells
have this enzyme is it has a pretty
complex biochemistry
that links with environmental conditions
so that's always interesting to
an environmental microbiologist like
myself
it comes in three classes there's class
one
which is the oxygen-dependent version of
the enzyme
class two which is oxygen independent
but is dependent on b12 cobalamin as
its cofactor and then an oxygen
sensitive version
uh which is found only in anoxic
environments
and really class one has the most
complexity
it also has diff it has different uh
metallic
cofactor requirements which is another
interesting thing
knowing the importance uh as we do of
micronutrients particularly iron um
so if you'll notice here in that
metallic cofactor
column uh a row at the bottom it can use
manganese it can use iron or possibly
none
and so when we look through the
environment do we see
links between the types of
ribonucleotides
are sorry rnr's that are carried by
viruses and
the prevailing environmental conditions
there has been as i mentioned earlier an
explosion in the availability of viral
metagenome sequence data
and one project that has contributed an
enormous amount of data has been
the terra ocean study and amelia
harrison my student has looked deeply
into
these libraries and uncovered this is an
old slide
we're now up to you know 20 000
something sequences
out of uh rnr's out of viruses and
um we've been able to demonstrate
entirely new um biochemical possibly new
biochemical classes of of
rnr's and what this is pointing out that
in the terra oceans data
which is largely the surface ocean um
maybe down to a few hundred meters
definitely
an oxygen-rich environment uh only
four class three rnr's were observed out
of
you know literally tens of thousands of
sequences and so
certainly the um the availability of
oxygen is certainly shaping the rnr's
that viruses are
are carrying
um and amelia discovered something kind
of well
something i think is very interesting um
that among the class one r and r's
we think we see a dramatic split
between the class the class
1 rnrs apologize the class 1 rnrs that
are seen
in cyanomyoviruses which are
look like t4 the one up at the top there
that has the
the long tail and the long tail fibers
um versus cyanopodoviruses
which is the one shown more in the
center of the slide with the short
little tail
um and these two groups of viruses have
very different tend to have very
different genome sizes cyanopodoviruses
have smaller genomes
cyanomyoviruses have tend to have large
genomes
upwards of 150 to 200 kb
and we see them in distinct groups
another interesting thing was that the
cyanosp class 1 enzymes
lacked regulatory domains and these
regulatory domains are
the domains that actually um
negatively regulate the activity of rnr
so that not
too many nucleotides are produced um
that it that it matches the level of dna
replication going on
well the class 1 enzymes in cyano
sp phages lack those domains which again
would make sense for a lytic viruses
that's just for a lytic virus that's
just
bent on producing more dna producing
more viruses
we also do see class 2 enzymes in
class 2 rnr's in cyanophages as well
and interestingly enough
cyano m and the cyano enclave the
cyanosp clade those are class one
enzymes whereas the host the
synecococcus host
um actually carries class two
enzymes so their viruses are even going
in a different direction
with the biochemical classes as opposed
to their hosts
and you know why is interesting these
two different viruses you know cyano
myoviruses versus cyano podoviruses
and um this slide shows a time series of
four viral of four
veroms that we collected in the
chesapeake bay over a 24-hour period
and eric sukowski a former student in
the lab
looked at the prevalence of these
different groups according to their r
r's over time within the libraries and
it turns out that
there really is an inverse relationship
between the abundance of these genes
over time
so it seems like the myoviruses
are you know quiet and infecting cells
while at the beginning whereas the
podoviruses are producing cells
are producing viruses and then they swap
places so there may be
this may be an example of niche
exclusion because both of these viruses
are infecting similar hosts
so our next question
was to actually link r and rs and poll
a's
and so what this slide shows is a
concatenated tree of r rs and pole a's
and what you can appreciate from this
this is
many uh many hundreds of of uh
contigs that are plotted here is that
when we have um a branch uh
which is uh the branches are
colored according to the r and r
they tend to be associated just with
just one type of pole a
either the phenylalanine tyrosine or
leucine
most of the clades behave in this way
and so is it possible that these clades
um like clay 4 clay 3 clade 6
share common life history strategies um
and uh and so that those are the
questions that we're we're continuing to
pursue
and so really i think to to summarize
um what we're trying to do is really
through is to bridge that gap evolution
when we look at a tree we're looking at
an evolutionary hypothesis
but what we're trying to do is link that
to the ecology of the virus
and the viral host system and the
biology of the viral host system and so
what we have in abundance right now
is the genome data what we're really
lacking is
the phenome data to tie together with
those genome hypotheses
of a viral life cycle so
along with uh colleagues at the
university of delaware
wrote university of rhode island uh the
university of nebraska university of
hawaii we
we started into an nsf's a large
nsf-supported study
to test genome-to-phenome hypotheses and
viruses of microbes
using high-throughput phenotyping
approaches that we wanna that we're
developing using microfluidics
um so really the bottleneck i believe in
in many of these questions
is the amount of phenotype data that we
can gather
and so we're hoping that microfluidics
can provide something
of a means of of improving that
throughput
and you know the idea is something like
this where
this is a a what i'm showing here on the
left is a
dichotomous key that um
eric and dan developed where literally
you start
um with the pole a group and then you
start to look outward from there
at the combinations of things that you
see and then
link those to individual
uh groups on the clades on the tree and
so
what this dichotomous key is showing is
that if we have a tyrosine 762 or
phenylalanine 762
with certain other gene connections we
would predict that these are
putative lytic potaviruses uh whereas if
we have a leucine 762
we predict maybe putative temperate
potaviruses
uh using these uh connections and and
sort of the
the grand vision here is to get to
something of
maybe a rule book for um
connecting uh genome to phenome
and here i show uh on the
on the left genes that are predictive of
the biology and ecology of
viruses like nucleotide metabolism genes
possibly structural genes
or auxiliary metabolic genes such as the
photosystem genes i mentioned earlier
there's we've also seen metabolic genes
associated with the sulfur cycle
um or phosphate availability
and then to link these to the biological
and ecological features of unknown
viruses which is shown
on the right and these are the
types of information that we want to
really fill in the gaps and and to
to have in much greater abundance and
that's
a goal of the um of our current nsf
project
so in closing i would like to
acknowledge um
many many folks over over the years who
have contributed to this work
we've had the fortune of going to lots
of different environments
and looking in at soils and sediments
much of our work has been in uh in
oceanic and marine systems
but we've also had the fortune of
working at deep sea hydrothermal vents
um had a few projects uh looking at the
human microbiome and the cattle
microbiome
um and we also have a pretty
uh vigorous bioinformatics
effort in the lab and that's the team
virum that i mentioned
over in the upper right and we've also
fortunately been sponsored
by many generous sponsors including
uh the hhmi uh the national science
foundation the gordon betty moore
foundation
uh the usda and the delaware epscor
program
so with that i thank you all for your
interest
and uh and look forward to your
questions